the craft of engraving is hundreds of
years old and this man has been in the
trade for the past half century Martin
riling is a master engraver and he says
hand engraving produces the best results
this is football it's more durable it
has a different structure than a machine
produces machine stamp or grind on when
we engrave we cut the material on our
people to know the English door riling
creates the Baroque style Viennese
engraving on pens uncover what he does
couldn't as far as the ending ravers who
are capable of doing that we think there
are four or five in Germany thankfully
we have one of them here higher than the
phone we're very happy about that it's a
unique feature of a product series from
our collection and it's very much in
demand each pen is unique yes I've
kaleido star doing oh and when he can't
Stefan cherish has managed the company
for eight years
the company places a lot of importance
on handcraft many processes have
remained unchanged for decades sterling
silver is pre-cut pressed into shape and
polished waldman produced 120,000 pens
this year that's a lot of work for their
20 employees and things always get a
little hectic in the months before
Christmas this fortunate Vegas you order
that really only works or only works
this year with a lot of overtime we work
Saturdays and during the week from half
past six in the morning to five or six
pm I'm all biden the company is looking
to hire for more workers but they're not
that easy to find there are plenty of
good employers in southern Germany and
people tend to stay put Maria Schnabel
has been putting pens together for half
her life convincing I've been doing it
for 25 years we're a family the handmade
pens are a luxury product ID read that
sure it's a premium product it's not
something the average person has at home
edenton the monument at the smith to
Hosea Waldman aims to outdo its
competitors with special commissions
Ben's like this for example were sold to
clients in Dubai quantify function it
has a portrait of sheikh al maktoum here
with the boards Khalifa up kabil did ya
bush or the Burj Al Arab dubai's main
landmarks this was a small production
run which we delivered as question what
do they cost that's all well if you've
had to buy it than I imagined you'd need
more than five or six hundred euros both
info about 600 we needed so one day
behind some of the most loyal customers
come from the car industry
an expensive car comes with some
expensive extras Tessa Mona srinagar
shift if we had a nice order from
rolls-royce they sent us the leather
they were using in their cars and we
turned it into a complete Penn
completing skiff and these were given to
customers who bought a rolls-royce then
they can the pens are polished after
every manufacturing step
polishing is another time-honored
handcraft expensive pens need to shine
the company sells its hand engraved pens
in more than 60 countries artistic craft
work made in Germany